[Música]
en este nuevo episodio de línea directa
estamos en las canarias donde la llegada
de los migrantes provenientes de costas
africanas que se multiplica desde el mes
de enero este archipiélago español no
había tenido una crisis migratoria
semejante desde hace más de 10 años y
las transferencias hacia el continente
europeo son cada vez más escasas vamos a
encontrarnos con algunas de las personas
que cruzaron el atlántico con la
esperanza de tener un mejor futuro nos
salieron desde marruecos y por fin
tocaron tierra firme
m
ellos vienen desde senegal y recorrieron
1400 kilómetros en esta embarcación
otros lo lograron gracias a un rescate
árbol
i
fuera del contexto de la pandemia las
islas canarias son un destino turístico
apreciado
[Música]
pero desde el mes de enero este
archipiélago español se convirtió en una
nueva puerta de entrada a europa para
más de 18 mil migrantes estos hombres y
mujeres huyen de los conflictos de la
precariedad pero también de la crisis
económica provocada por la pandemia los
refuerzos de los controles en otras
rutas migratorias en el norte de
marruecos y en el mediterráneo los
llevaron a cruzar el atlántico desde
agosto y durante tres meses el puerto de
arguineguín fue transformado en un
campamento de emergencia para
identificar a los migrantes y efectuar
los de pista hess de kobe del 19 se
convirtió entonces en el símbolo de la
falta de infraestructuras humanitarias y
fue bautizado en el muelle de la
vergüenza a mediados de noviembre nos
encontramos con txema santana quien
documenta esta crisis migratoria para su
ong la comisión española de ayuda para
los refugiados pues mira en estos
trescientos noventa y ocho metros de
largo que tiene estas cocheras que han
acumulado miles de personas durante este
2020 porque es el punto más al sur el
puerto seguro más cercano más al sur de
las islas canarias y por tanto todas las
acciones que se rescatan al sur de
canarias o la mayoría de ellas se traen
hasta este muelle y no es un fenómeno
nuevo es un fenómeno que se viene dando
durante el último cuarto de siglo
canarias de fronteras de europa y lo que
sí es nuevo es que estamos viendo que
desde el mes de septiembre se han
incorporado a esta ruta migratoria
ensanchando las personas afectadas
económicas por la pandemia en noviembre
a veces había hasta 2000 durmiendo en
este campamento previsto para 400
personas
la alcaldesa de la ciudad fue de las
primeras en denunciar esta situación
y estos meses de acogida humanitaria
donde el muelle ha estado a disposición
de estas personas para cogerlo uno de
los días que te rompiste y llorar un
poco no pues claro en las primeras
carpas habían mujeres y niños es decir
yo soy madre de una hija de tres años
entonces cuando yo vi esas imágenes de
esos niños vi a mi hija
me rompí todas porque digo que está
haciendo españa que estamos haciendo
nosotros que no somos capaces de dar
respuesta a un problema humanitario
en un vídeo aquí que ha sido viral que
me gustaría enseñarte vale
detrás de ellos están las casetas de
campaña están durmiendo a la intemperie
ni siquiera con carpas y eso es alguien
y eso es dentro del mallorquín en la
entrada al puerto estaba prohibida para
los periodistas para preservar la
intimidad de las personas
[Música]
hasta aquí podemos venir pero ahí las
críticas finalmente fueron escuchadas la
noche del 29 de noviembre poco después
de nuestra grabación por primera vez
desde agosto ningún migrante durmió en
el campamento de emergencia de
arguineguín todos fueron transferidos
hacia nuevas infraestructuras
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en las canarias la llegada de los
migrantes divide a la población por un
lado algunos hacen un llamado a la
solidaridad
[Música]
no no
por otro con los habitantes irritados se
ven que estas llegadas tengan un mayor
impacto sobre el sector turístico que ya
es también afectada
[Aplausos]
el ministro español del interior
fernando grande-marlaska lo afirmo no
quiere que las canarias se transformen
en un nuevo les voz el 20 de noviembre
españa anunció un plan de emergencia con
el objetivo de crear 7000 espacios de
albergue en el archipiélago
[Música]
el gobierno de español quiso evitar las
transferencias hacia el continente
europeo y quiere llevar a cabo una
política de retorno sin embargo la
pandemia y el cierre de las fronteras
volvieron las expulsiones imposibles
llegados hace un mes estos marroquíes ya
tienen la impresión de estar frente a un
callejón sin salida uno de ellos acepta
hablar con nosotros al igual que la
mayor parte de los migrantes pide
permanecer anónimo
pero mucho más
no el pp
porque nadie ayuda aquí sin pasaporte no
se puede ir a ningún lugar
para que estas fotos son mis hijos mi
hija y mi hijo andrés es maestra y esto
es mi diploma de bachillerato y esta es
mi licencia de inglés
en inglés cuando estaba en marruecos
escuché que si uno es un hombre
instruido es posible recibir ayuda en
europa
help and youth that's why braingate with
me
entretanto los hoteles vacíos de sus
turistas albergan a alrededor de 5.000
migrantes con ayuda de la cruz roja
estamos lejos de las condiciones
precarias del muelle de arguineguín
incluso aunque para muchos las canarias
no sean más que una etapa vendemos
yo quiero viajar españa porque en españa
tengo familia
queremos reunirnos con nuestra familia
queremos trabajar el tener un oficial
[Música]
el días de noviembre un avión que
transportaba a 22 migrantes expulsados
de las canarias aterrizó en mauritania
es el primero desde el mes de marzo unos
acuerdos de retorno también debían
haberse reactivado con senegal y
marruecos
la única opción para escapar de una
expulsión es pedir asilo es lo que hizo
este emigrante de guinea que txema
santana nos presentó en las palmas la
capital de gran canarias explica haber
sido amenazado después de unas
manifestaciones políticas en su país por
su seguridad no mostrará su rostro
expliqué mi problema me dijeron que
debía empezar el proceso administrativo
pero yo les pediría que me ayuden a
llegar hasta españa continental no
conozco a nadie entonces que me
transfieran a donde haya un lugar para
mí que le gustaría hacer después como me
dijeron eso dependerá de mi nivel de
español en función de eso haré una
formación para mi integración a la
sociedad española por ahora recibo
clases todos los días gracias al
programa de asilo en la ciudad y todo va
muy bien
[Música]
las cifras son difíciles de obtener pero
según la organización internacional para
la migración al menos 500 personas han
perdido la vida tratando de llegar hasta
las canarias desde enero en el mismo
periodo el salvamento marítimo ha
coordinado el rescate de casi 10.000
personas
se trata de un cayuco tipo senegalés son
embarcaciones fuertes
el gran problema que suelen tener es que
la travesía es muy larga son muchos días
son más de 10 días 9 10 días o más no
tienen medios de salvamento no tienen
medios de poder señalizar si tienen un
problema o avisar porque no hay
cobertura telefónica no hay nada los
rescatistas marítimos son prevenidos
sobre casos de embarcaciones en peligro
por ongs radares o navíos mercantes la
zona de búsqueda y rescate alrededor de
las canarias es inmensa equivale casi al
doble de la superficie del territorio
español los rescatistas deben estar
preparados para todas las situaciones a
veces pues se encuentra a la gente de
mal estado deshidratada
e inconsciente de incluso se han dado el
caso de nacer niños en la embarcación de
la misma patera y tener que actuar la
tripulación de salvamento para cortar el
cordón umbilical a principios de
noviembre en senegal la historia de
download fallo fue particularmente
conmovedor a este adolescente de 14 años
soñaba con jugar fútbol en europa su
padre lo embarcó hacia las canarias
murió durante el trayecto
muchos menores viajan solos al llegar le
corresponde al gobierno de las canarias
encargarse de ellos 21 centros de
acogida de emergencia se abrieron desde
el principio del año el de la ciudad de
ayagaures aloja a 24 jóvenes
estas son las habitaciones de los chicos
actualmente distribuimos las
habitaciones en cuatro donde duermen 66
chicos esto forma parte también el salón
donde ellos tienen sus espacios
una vez los menores llegan en pateras
ellos son declarados menores de edad
bien porque ellos se declaran o porque
la policía así lo establece una vez aquí
comenzamos ya su itinerario ya no sólo
educativo sino también más
administrativo donde ya hay menores que
han sido decretado como menores de edad
y están los que están pendientes de las
pruebas pertinentes las pruebas o sea
donde se decretara la edad que tiene el
cine
[Música]
no
es eso
ya tengo 16 años me fui de senegal
el camino no fue fácil
había muchas olas el clima era malo nos
demoramos cinco días en llegar aquí
solo le había avisado a tu familia que
te ibas nadie sabía de la casa nadie
sabía dónde estaba
en el centro los que todavía esperan el
resultado de las pruebas óseas
permanecen inquietos y quisieran poder
hacer planes
realmente estamos impacientes por
hacernos la prueba queremos que el
resultado demuestra que somos menores
para poder quedarnos aquí y estudiar
cuando uno llega del idioma hay que
empezar por el alfabeto trato de leer y
de entender pero todavía no sé lo que
dice este libro en sanjuan automóvil en
este pequeño salón los jóvenes empiezan
a aprender español si en efecto son
declarados menores podrán ir al colegio
y serán protegidos hasta su mayoría de
edad serán parte de los pocos migrantes
en tener una oportunidad en empezar una
nueva etapa
[Música]